problem 43
mia found the area of this shape by
dividing it into rectangles as shown so
she divided them into rectangles mia
could use the same method to find the
area for which of these shapes
so essentially she's you know what what
technique can we use to divide it by we
could figure out the area by dividing it
into rectangles
so let's see what do we have here can we
divide this interaction we could divide
it into a bunch of triangles or you know
we could we could draw a bunch of
triangles but we can't divide this into
a bunch of
rectangles or we could have done it we
could do it this way as well there's
multiple ways to think about it you
could have it you could have it like
this and you could draw a bunch of
triangles like that
but you can't divide this into
rectangles
this one here
this one here you can't divide it into
rectangles you could divide into
triangles and rectangles but not
necessarily just rectangles and this
here i really don't know what it looks
like there's some type of typo in in my
in my test because obviously i can
divide
both of these things right here into
well i mean i just the way i'm looking
at it i see squares here so obviously i
can divide that into rectangles but my
guess is if i had to guess is that this
was a triangle maybe before
if it was a triangle then i couldn't
draw it divide this into rectangles but
maybe this was something like this maybe
this looked
maybe this looked something like this i
don't know i'm only guessing if it did
look like this and we could divide it
into rectangles the same way that she
did up here and figure out its area so
assuming that there was some type of
typo in this problem i'm going to go
with choice d if choice d was supposed
to look like a figure like that then you
could actually divide it into a bunch of
rectangles
problem 44 oh i see you know what these
were probably were these were probably
the right angle these were probably to
show us that these are right angles
right there
so that that's a right angle
that's a right angle and maybe well i
don't know what else they were trying to
show us maybe
maybe well who knows well you see what
i'm going at these look there's clearly
some type of typo on that problem
forty-four simplify x squared minus
three x plus one minus x squared plus
two x plus seven
so let's just write it out we have x
squared minus three x plus one then we
have to distribute this minus sign so
minus x squared
minus x squared
minus two x right minus times plus so
minus
two x
minus times plus seven is minus seven so
you have an x squared minus an x squared
they cancel out right x squared minus x
squared is zero
then you have minus three x minus two x
so minus three x minus two x is minus
five x
and then you have one
minus seven which is minus six
so you're left with minus five x minus
six
which is choice c
problem 45
what
are the coordinates of the x-intercept
of the line
3x plus 4y is equal to 12. there i want
to know the x-intercept remember the
x-intercept if this is a line and this
is a line let me draw the axes
and say the line looks you know i don't
know what it looks like say the line
looks something like this the
x-intercept is the value
when y is equal to zero so this is going
to be
you know the x-intercept is going to be
some value
x
and
zero so let's figure out what this
x-intercept is so we can even look here
this is definitely not an x-intercept
this is a y-intercept this is a
y-intercept in order to be an
x-intercept in order to be on the x-axis
your y-value has to be zero so the
choices are either b or d
and so if y is zero let's just solve the
equation if y is it so three x plus 4
times 0
is equal to 12 or we get 3 x is equal to
12 right that's just 0 right there so x
is equal to 4. so the x intercept is 4
comma 0. x is four y is zero so this is
our choice right there
forty six which of the following
statement describes parallel lines and
parallel lines are just two lines
that never intersect that have the same
slope and they don't sit on top of each
other so those would be two parallel
lines right there
same y-intercepts but different slopes
no i just said they have to have the
same slope and they never intersect so
they can't have the same y-intercepts
it's not that one same slope but
different y-intercepts that looks right
they're parallel but they're not on top
of each other there or they have the
same slope opposite slopes and if they
had opposite slopes they would intersect
we can't be that opposite x-intercepts
but same y-intercepts no that's not
sorry the case so our answer is b